apple
threatens to ban facebook and
instagram and they actually did it but
that's a story from the sun facebook and
instagram threatened with a band from
iphone after secret slave market
uncovered on apps apple threatened to
ban facebook from the iphone after an
investigation found that its app were
used for human trafficking the frackers
began in 2019 after the bbc reported
that human traffickers in the middle
east were using facebook apps to arrange
sales of victims
used by users in saudi arabia and kuwait
featured adverts of the illegal buying
and selling of domestic slaves against
their will women were sold for a few
thousand dollars each categorized by
race and deprived of their basic human
rights they were unable to leave in
response to the investigation apple told
facebook that it would ban its products
unless action was taken this is not a
small ban by the way can you imagine
facebook and instagram are no longer on
apple that's a big hit if that were to
take place that's huge go back exactly
two months and what what was apple
upset about they were getting hit
right hey your devices are listening to
us hey you're not doing this remember
apple was getting hit yes now apple was
getting hit and who was coming after
apple right the first people that come
after privacy on apple is not the
conservatives it's the liberals those
are the first people that come running
down the street i think that
both parties think that there's a
serious issue in silicon valley i think
most americans think this apple's taking
it in the chops two months ago big in
the chops about
the listening the camera that turns on
by itself not which isn't really turning
on by itself it's way designed et cetera
et cetera et cetera now you've got
i believe apple is doing the right thing
but and that by the way they also have
problems with their own employees
remember their own employees were
talking about salaries they were talking
about a whole bunch of stuff they were
talking about working conditions and
factories so two months ago tim is like
okay what do i got to do here well i
have to take an altruistic stance
number one and i also need to take a
stance and lock step with the with the
us government specifically the
department of commerce and the
foreigners that are running it so
i think that's what apple did i think
apple has taken a stance it's altruistic
they're trying to align themselves with
the us government the us government is
still
you know
still got the scope down their throat
looking at what's going on and i think
apple had to move this direction who
needs who by the way this is a great
example of who needs to does apple need
facebook or facebook need apple good
question that's that's very facebook
needs apps you always need distribution
right and what's and what's happening
that's right in just these past few days
i mean have we all not updated our
phones because for the first time in how
long apple was like our security's been
breached yep
and i'm like wait a minute most of these
ios upgrades whatever but no apple is
announcing to people
we screwed up somebody got into our
system you have to download this upgrade
or you're going to be
infiltrated whatever i mean it was it to
me that was a big admission that nobody
picked up on
but my i.t person immediately was like
danielle there's a bug in apple
upgrade your phone immediately there's a
bug in apple upgrade your macbook
immediately
but the story here is about this secret
slave market yeah so we're not even
touching we're you're saying you're
saying that that is a small sliver of an
issue and the privacy issues outweigh
that it is a huge issue
but
the social media and technology elite in
silicon valley have done little for 10
years to prevent the weaponization of
the tools they built by really bad
people and you can
move you're saying human trafficking is
terrible but you could you could sit
there search and replace that with all
these other things that really bad
people are doing everything from drug
trafficking to human trafficking to well
remember news this is an offshoot of
this is a little case example of the
bigger
big tech issues that we're facing is
what you're saying i mean terribly bad
horrible people around the world are
using apple and facebook and instagram
apparently
um there were member in new zealand
there was a mass shooting yeah and that
was that they brought all the bad people
together on facebook so and they're
censoring
americans from having open discourse so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]